don't be hard on yourself for rebounding
when an animal does you know it's not
like dating you're allowed to try to
replace the thing few years ago end up
getting a job in Los Angeles we had our
caps digits and ends Oh kids it's like a
sweet calico cat a little thick but it's
all muscle Enzo is a gray marble the
super affectionate cat within two weeks
of being in the apartment I get a phone
call and it's my girlfriend and she's
just sobbing on the phone Enzo's dead
my girlfriend watched the cat jump up
onto the the sill of this window comenzó
fell nine stories to his death I go back
home to downtown LA I see my girlfriend
holding a bloody towel all of a sudden I
hear symbol out rap music and it's my
friend Jimmy and he rolls up in a
totally sick convertible Mustang
long story short Jimmy and I have to
sort of figure out how we can dispose of
my really sweet dead cat downtown Los
Angeles has no yards even the park is
full of cement there is a moment where
I'm like could I like bury it in
Griffith Park so we look for a vet that
can actually incinerate this body we end
up finding one and we show up in the
convertible top down I bring the cat in
and the vet walks in and says Oh house
Enzo doing and then I have to sort of
explain to the vet tech that the cat is
in fact dead inside of the towel the vet
tech was super helpful and gave me lots
of options I could get Enzo's ashes in
an urn they they were very accepting of
all payment type it turns out so I say
can you take him and incinerate him I
don't eat the ashes I don't anything
special the vet tech politely takes Enzo
from me in the towel as I'm leaving
walking out of the vet the vet tech like
emerges from the back hey man look you
need this towel he's like dangling this
towel that has cat blood all over it and
like no please no thank you leave me
alone sir
two days later it's the weekend my
girlfriend and I are breathing we go to
the desert to find the peace my
girlfriend I both see a sign on the side
where that says Yucca Valley animal
shelter we go to the animal shelter they
give us two options one is this kind of
old lady cat missing some fur a little
cross-eyed and the other cat they show
us is this beautiful orange marbled cat
and it looks exactly like Enzo we drove
it home and we named him loverboy and
he's been our little loverboy ever since
[Music]